so
this is a bit of a tangent but you've uh
talked with sam
uh harris on that four hour special
episode we mentioned
and um i just curious to ask because i
use this meditation app i've been using
the past month to meditate is this
something you've integrated
as part of your life meditation or
fasting or has
has some of sam harris rubbed off on you
in terms of his appreciation of
of uh meditation and just kind of from a
third person perspective analyzing your
own mind
consciousness free will and so on you
know i have tried it three separate
times in my life
really made a concerted attack on
meditation
and integrating it into my life um one
of them the most extreme was i
i took a class based on the work of john
kabat-zinn
uh who is you know in many ways one of
the the founding
people behind the mindful meditation
movement and that required like part of
the class was
you know it was a weekly class and you
were going to meditate an
hour a day every day and having done
that
for i think was 10 weeks it might have
been 13 however long period of time was
at the end of it it just didn't stick as
soon as it was over
you know i did not feel that
gravitational pull i did not feel
the collapse in quality of life after
wimping out on that on that project and
then the most recent one was actually
with sam's app
uh during during the lockdown i did make
a
pretty good and consistent concerted
effort to
listen to his 10-minute meditation every
day and i've always
fallen away from it and i i you know
you're kind of interpreting why did i
personally do this
i do believe it was ultimately because
it wasn't
bringing me that you know joy or inner
peace or
better competence at being me that i was
hoping to get from it
otherwise i think i would have clung to
it in the way that we cling to certain
good habits like i'm really good at
flossing my teeth not that you were
going to
ask lex but yeah that's one thing that
defeats a lot of people i'm good at that
see uh herman hesse i think uh if you
know which book or maybe
i forget where i've read everything of
his so it's
it's unclear uh where he came from but
he had this idea that
anybody who is um
who truly achieves mastery in things
will learn how to meditate in some way
so it could be the
that for you the flossing of teeth is is
yet another
like little inkling of meditation like
it doesn't have to be this very
particular kind of meditation maybe
podcasting you have an amazing podcast
that could be meditation the writing
process is meditation
for me like
there's there's a bunch of there's a
bunch of mechanisms which take my mind
into a very particular place that looks
a whole lot like meditation
for example when i've been running
uh for the over the past couple years
and um
especially when i listen to certain
kinds of audiobooks
like i've listened to the rise and fall
of the third reich i've
i've listened to a lot of sort of world
war ii which
at once because i have a lot of family
was
lost in world war ii and so so much of
the soviet union is grounded in the
suffering of world war ii
that somehow it connects me to my
history but also
there's some kind of purifying aspect to
thinking about how cruel
but at the same time how beautiful human
nature could be and so you're also
running
like it clears the mind from all the
concerns of the world and somehow it
takes you to this place where you're
like
deeply appreciative to be alive in the
sense that
as opposed to listening to your breath
or like feeling your breath
and thinking about your consciousness
and all those kinds of processes
that uh sam's app does well this does
that for me
the the running and flossing may do that
for you
so maybe herman has these on to
something so yeah i hope flossing is not
my main form of expertise although i am
going to claim a certain expertise there
and i'm going to claim
somebody has to be the best flosser in
the world that ain't me i'm just glad
that i'm a consistent one i mean there
are a lot of things that bring me into a
flow state and i think maybe
perhaps that's one reason why meditation
isn't as necessary for me
um i definitely enter a flow state when
i'm writing i'm definitely enter a flow
state when i'm editing i definitely
enter a flow state when i'm mixing and
mastering music
um i enter a flow state when i'm doing
heavy heavy research
to either prepare for a podcast or to
also do tech investing you know to make
myself smart
in a a new field that is fairly alien to
me
um i can just the hours can just melt
away
while i'm you know reading this and
watching that youtube lecture and
you know going through this presentation
and so forth so maybe because there's a
lot of things that bring me into a flow
state
in my normal weekly life not daily
unfortunately but certainly my normal
weekly life
that i have less of an urge to meditate
you've been working with sam's app
for about a month now you said um is
this your first run in with meditation
it's your first attempt to integrate it
with with your life for
like meditation meditation yeah i always
thought running and thinking
i listened to brown noise often that
takes my mind
i don't know what the hell it does but
it takes my mind immediately into like
the state where i'm deeply focused on
anything i do
i don't know why so it's like you're
accompanying sound when you're yeah
really what's the difference between
brown and white noise this is a cool
term i haven't heard before
so people should look up brown noise
they don't have to because you're about
to tell them what it is well
because you have to experience they have
to listen to it so i think white noise
is uh this is this has to do with music
i think
there's different colors there's pink
noise and i think that has to do with uh
like the frequencies like the white
noise is usually
uh less bassy brow noise is very bassy
so it's more like like versus like
like the if that makes sense so yeah
it take there's like a deepness to it i
think it everyone is different but for
me
uh i i was it was when i was uh
i was a research scientist at mit when i
would especially when there's a lot of
students around
i remember just being annoyed at the
noise of people talking
and one of my colleagues said well you
should try listening to brown noise
like it really knocks out everything
because i used to wear your earplugs too
like just see if i can block it out
and one like the moment i put it on
something
it's as if my mind was waiting all these
years
to hear that sound everything's just
focused and i
listen it makes me wonder how many other
amazing things out there they're
waiting to discover from my own
particular
like biological for my own particular
brain so that
it just goes the mind just focuses in is
kind of incredible
so i see that as a kind of meditation
maybe uh
i'm using a performance enhancing uh uh
sound to achieve that meditation but
i've been doing that for
for many years now and running and
walking and doing um
cal newport was the first person that
introduced me to the idea of deep work
just put a word to the kind of thinking
that's required to sort of deeply think
about a problem especially if it's
mathematical in nature
i see that as a kind of meditation
because what it's doing is you're
you have these constructs in your mind
that you're building on top of each
other
and there's all these distracting
thoughts that keep bombarding you
from all over the place and the whole
process is you you slowly let them kind
of
move past you and that's a meditative
process it's very meditative that sounds
a lot like what
sam talks about um in his meditation app
which i did use to be clear for a while
of just letting the thought go by
without deranging you derangement is one
of sam's favorite words as i'm sure you
know
um but uh brown noise that's really
intriguing i am i am going to try that
as soon as this evening
yeah to see to see if it works but very
well might not work at all
you